up next
we have francis becker such a great
pleasure to uh to join with you this
evening discussing
israel that's important to the united
stand
thank you for your wonderful speech
tonight and for being the amazing
conservative that you are and uh
better yes
is
we did a rally ten thousand people
showed up he didn't hear about it
we'll be there again a solid service
online because they plan to open
the triumphal mosque on the cherished
site of concord land
on september 11 2011 but i'm stealing
your time
no that's all right glad you're uh
warming the public
uh my name is train background running
for congress uh
district you're hearing a lot of speak
and talk about
support for israel tonight um but
you have to wonder is it being said just
because it's politically expedient that
somebody
say that they supported zero after all
it is it is campaign time
for me you may not be able to
look into somebody's heart or you may
not be able to read somebody's mind
certainly can't do that that's not
possible but you can determine a
person's who that person
are the words that they may be saying is
to be true
if you see or try to understand or find
out about a person's background
and if you were to look into my
background you knew
that i grew up in in limbo
and a family that raised me to be a man
of faith
i was raised to know that christian
judeo-christian values
are what made the united states great
when i went to high school at liberty
high school
better than half the students there were
jewish
and i had the blessing of having many
many
jewish friends in high school
they came to our uh we went to their bar
mitzvahs and barnminsters
and they came to our confirmations and
it was then that my journey to
understand
understanding and appreciating the judeo
portion of the judeo-christian
traditions and values
began for me
and it was at that time also that it
began
that i started to understand that not
only was there a
spiritual connection between jews
and christians but there was a strategic
very important relationship
between the united states
and israel
i don't think if i'm fortunate enough to
be elected
that it's just good enough to go to
washington
just to support some bills
and even to fight for israel
if i'm fortunate enough to be elected i
think that
it's my obligation and it's for me my
personal mission to do far more than
that
my mission will be to help to reach out
to other members of congress who may not
have understand
who may not have had the same wonderful
experience that i did growing up
and understanding the great jewish
traditions
that this country values and has been so
much a part of this nation
i will help other members understand
that aid to israel the billions of
dollars that we provide from them
each and every year benefits not only
israel
but benefits the united states of
america
it benefits us because israel is truly
important to us
they bring back jobs and they send that
money back to us
they are a cheap partner i will help and
work to help others
in the house in washington understand
that the flotilla crisis was simply a
sham
the whole the whole thing was designed
to set up our great ally and make them
look bad
for the rest of the day
i will help them understand because i
bet a lot don't even know
that israel is the only true democracy
presently in the middle east there is no
other democracy
and somebody a good friend of mine
pointed out to me today
that one of the reasons that they fear
israel one of the reasons
is that if that if democracy spreads
throughout the middle east that all
saudi arabia all these great cheeks and
shahs and whatever they are
will lose their great power and have to
be common
answerable to the rest of the citizens
of their of their of their countries
i will help them also understand that
the united states of the united nations
and its investigation of israel in the
current war
was also a sham and once again all the
united states intentioned the united
nations intentions is doing
is to try to belittle and make uh israel
look bad in the rest of
the rest of the world and i support the
bill that peter king
uh proposed that actually why not pull
the funding and get out from underneath
the i don't care what app says it's
totally ridiculous
um i have to say booms who have the
worst
human rights
positions are permitted to make judgment
on other people
i think it's a sham and i think it's a
disgrace and
peter king is right
this is very important i would help them
to understand
my colleagues in congress and i will
work hard to do this
that we must have
a strong united states
military and we must have a strong
presence in the entire world that is
respected
because right now you take a look at
turkey
what have they done they've jumped in to
the uh to the to the lie
of the arab world because we're
becoming and perceived to be weak in
this in the world they are
our military
israel can only depend on us
and us depend on them if the united
states has a strong military
and we're seeing that as pandra said
that
the american exceptionalism the concept
of it
is quickly vanishing and as bruce said
the united states is the last great hope
of the entire world
and you would think that it would have
changed over the years but ladies and
gentlemen has not
in fact is becoming more and more
evident and now
with obama and pelosi and reid
diminishing this great nation's
character and its military and
everything about us
is making us weak and emboldening our
enemies
and as a result it's weakening
israel's safety and that is a great
great concern to me
if you don't have that big strong older
brother there
ready to say hey don't pick on that
person not that israel needs us
entirely to defend it in each everything
it does but sometimes you have to stand
back
and say let there be at least a fair
fight right
let there at least be a fair fight if
you have the big old brother saying all
right you go ask it but this alone has
three and four others don't jump in the
fight
and hurt that person because i think my
personal feeling is
israel can well defend itself if it's a
fair fight
there's one other thing that's in my
opinion critically important
we're seeing a financial collapse in our
nation
we have stimulus packages that haven't
created the job
and not even one job is certainly not a
job in
nassau county and i have to say that my
opponent carol mccarthy
has voted 97 of the time for the obama
pelosi and reed
team and that is i don't think
if you please tell me if you disagree i
don't think that's representative
of this district and the way people feel
in the fourth congressional district
what i'm saying though is if america
there was a my daughter who was helping
me with my camera
and i love her it's wonderful to have
the internet and she's out in california
and she's
constantly sending me uh articles uh
and uh she's also helping me with
facebook which i have no idea
what to do you know i even said you you
befriend them and they said oh
dad please it's terrible it's not that
that's not what it is
but it was studied by the congregation
the congressional budget office said
within the last couple of days
that a weak united states financial
structure
or or when as we pile this debt upon
debt
weakens us as a nation so that if there
is a war that we must fight
we will not have the financial resources
so we're heading through very very
difficult times
and of course if i were so
lucky to be your representative in
congress
one thing that i believe in to the very
core of myself and you and i
explained to you from where i came from
and why i feel the way i do
and why i feel so passionate about
israel
and in the judeo traditions
is i firmly believe that the sooner the
better that we make jerusalem
the capital of israel the better and i
will go to washington
you the police said the undivided
eternal capital israel
jerusalem which is very very significant
to me certainly if
you read the bible as i knew i said very
very powerful so um
i just want to mention one other thing
i've served in the national county
legislature four
seven terms and i've learned an awful
lot
one of the things that i've learned i've
learned really how to fight
and i had a fight against tax increases
over the past eight terms over and over
again
i had to fight against increased
spending and then something came down
the pipe called an energy tax
and uh this was an appalling thing to me
in the sense that
now i don't want another this is a mixed
audience but i'm republican
and you know the democrats always claim
that they're concerned about the
minorities
but the energy tax was more damaging
and more aggressive to the minority
community than
any tax that ever had been imposed on
this county
and uh i have to get rid of my
republican colleagues we
fought and we repealed that energy tag
so
what i'm suggesting to you is that
i want to fight i want to go down there
i want to i want to fight in washington
for you and of course
for the future of our country as pam so
wonderfully expressed just moments
ago and you're doing a great job on the
on the media in the air but
let me be the soldier okay you'll be the
gym i'll go down there and i'll fight
and i just i just like to do uh if i can
and wrap up i don't know much more time
i just want to once again
uh howard koppel uh is my fellow
cognitive
colleague
i i could not uh not uh finish without
acknowledging how because you're you and
i have
been great friends and resources to me
and have taken even further
on that journey along understanding and
appreciating
israel and the jewish and
judeo-christian
traditions thank you so i'll answer any
questions
and you know what what amazes me
especially with the democratic party and
obama
is i think they're totally out of touch
with us i think they're totally out of
touch
with the people that they're supposed to
represent and uh and i just uh of course
like you you're probably wondering well
how can this be
how much longer can it go on but i think
you know i congratulate
the tea party people and and becoming
i'm so glad you you you've joined the
fight it's significant i've been to many
many of your functions
and uh and debates and so forth and i
encourage you just to keep on going
and to and to continue the fight and uh
and with your help with your help we're
gonna have some changes this november i
feel it i feel it in the wind
i feel it in my heart and you know
something failure is not an option
if we don't win in november we will fail
and we will fail
and that can't happen
on long island unfortunately and and i
know the tea party people
are working on this uh the gang of four
we only have really one congressman on
long island at this particular point and
that's peter king
i would love
i would love for you to support me and
consider supporting me because i
tell you i will stand on peter's king's
shoulders okay
and and shout aloud as hard as he
is and does and it will be wonderful to
just to go to washington and serve
beside him as another voice
as another rock a rock for israel
it's all about money you know
that those issues you're talking about
the obamacare which if we're not broke
already
uh when it comes into effect will
certainly bank up our nation
and as my colleague bruce blakeman who i
by the way served on the county
legislature with him for many years and
was just an
amazing guy we have to take the money
away
we have to defund every one of these
programs and really that's
yes well first of all that's a there's a
long long
talk on that particular question but
what you're saying is not totally
accurate you have to remember that in
the
last eight years uh squashing the
democrats
in charge and prior to that
and they're the ones by the way that
instituted the energy tax and raised
taxes okay this isn't the place
it's kind of a long answer but time to
lie when the legislature first came in
the county was already in financial
financial trouble with the water
supervisor but
the important question is and i would
like to you know you're talking about
finances
and just briefly i would like everyone
if they could take a moment that it's in
my brochure
i don't want i'm running out of time but
i have a five-point plan
uh for uh financial recovery to restore
jobs to america and restore the american
dream
would you go to my website becker for
congress and just review it i think
it'll make a lot of sense to you
and that's what i'm going to fight for
and once again it was a great pleasure
you